all right so one of the things that I
thought about in trying to tackle the
Lord of the Rings the rings of power is
figuring out a way to get inside the
material and take you along on this
journey and for me the best way to do
that is with themes so I mapped out all
the different characters that I thought
might need a theme and all the different
factions and I'm shooting for like that
sweet spot of maybe four or five and the
list came back 17 and I thought that's
just too many but as I as I dug into the
show I realized we really needed 17
discreet pieces of music that would
allow you to follow these different
characters on their journey through
Middle Earth
so how do you make that work well you
know you you have an orchestra you're
going to hear an orchestra you're going
to hear solos from around the world
you're going to hear choirs but at the
end of the day it all started in my
studio at the piano a theme to be
memorable really only needs to be
something that you can play with one
finger sitting sitting at the piano so I
want to show you guys a little of my
creative process
as I started to score the rings of power
so um
I'll say Nori's theme that was the first
one I wrote I feel like she's a very
pure character she's very innocent
um so I wanted to create something that
felt the way that I felt when I thought
about her and I thought about her her
foot life
thank you
[Music]
so thank you
I feel like this tells us a lot about
who Nori is
um almost on the other end of the
spectrum the second piece that I decided
to write was for Kaza Doom uh and we've
already seen some of the the brilliant
actors that bring to life this
industrious people they are they are
motivated and they're Builders and
they're minors so I wanted to create
something that had this sense of
constant motion and I created a just a
an incredibly simple little anthem
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you there's a lot of power and
there's a lot of nobility but hidden in
there there's also vulnerability and
what I loved about Owen and Peter in
particular in their scenes together is
that you you understood the family
Dynamic there so I didn't need to change
the music I didn't need to change the
melody to capture some of that in their
in their confrontational scenes in one
scene in the middle of the season
o-line Prince Duran goes to his father
and asks for forgiveness and you hear
that same
prideful theme in a different context
foreign
[Music]
that's what I love about thematic
writing is that it can tell you about
the characters and it can tell you about
the place at the same time
now one of our characters has no place
Sauron is perhaps the most challenging
character for me to wrap my head around
as I started the season because he's
referenced obliquely for most of the
episode I wanted to create something
that sounded immediately Sinister and
also evoked
geometry of a ring
just a little circle going right back to
where it started
you hear how the melody just twists
around and I gave him this little motor
underneath
it just propels everything it's like a
like a it's like a a hornet's nest has
been stirred up when you talk about him
and combined they create this really
interesting feeling
[Music]
foreign
fun stuff
all right so
I felt like that feels pretty good I
understand who Sauron is but we also
meet a character named Hal brand
who is revealed to be Sauron and you see
Hal brand you get to know him you feel
like you understand his quest you
understand that he has a dark past but
you like him
well what am I going to do with this you
guys so I needed to figure out a way to
have a Hal brand theme
that could connect to the Sauron theme
so I turn it around backwards instead of
let's go the other way
feels too obvious it it it would give it
away so I tweaked one note
okay getting somewhere just by changing
the context now of that figure that
feels very sauron-esque you suddenly
feel
that's a noble man from the Southlands
is who's in front of you
[Music]
so what I love about that technique
thank you is it allows you to
subconsciously digest that there's a
similarity I don't expect anyone in here
understood that sauron's theme was a
backwards version of Hal Brand's theme
in fact I would argue I'm ruining the
show for you if that's what you're
thinking about
but it's there the similarities is there
the similarities are there that every
other character has these big leaping
beautiful themes and then how branz is
contained it's smaller
another character I struggled with uh
initially was elrond because I wanted to
create something very optimistic and
diplomatic he's we're meeting him at a
youthful time in his life
ah
but
there's something going on with this guy
he's displaced from his family he's an
outcast we've gone from the major to the
minor which is super weird it's really
weird to do that but don't worry
oh
we realize there's warmth to him
[Music]
so one of the things thank you
um I love playing with
contextualizing very simple Melodies I
think a simple Melody is one that you
remember
for example
valinor I wanted to create something
that's very simple and childlike
there's almost nothing to it
but it's a very idyllic place it's a
beautiful place but in the context of
the Rings of power it's a place that's
Out Of Reach so in writing harmonies for
this I wanted to take us far away far
away from our starting point
now we're going to go on a little
journey
okay get ready you guys
these chords are so weird and yet we
come back home
[Music]
there's something very beautiful and
longing about that even though it feels
weird it's just weird I love it
um
I think thank you I think maybe though
my my favorite theme is the Galadriel
theme Galadriel to me was my entry point
for this character I've Loved this
character since I was a kid she was my
entry point for this show
and when I was getting started I was
trying to find a way in who is Galadriel
and then when I saw
the shot of morphoth holding the helmets
she was holding a singular helmet
putting it on a pile of other helmets I
thought well here is tragedy and sorrow
strength
but also vulnerability and sadness and I
just started looking at that scene in
particular over and over again
and imagining a Melody that could
capture those feelings
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hi
I'm here now just as my true self a
massive fan of bear McCreery
um thank you so much for writing that oh
well you're welcome and thank you for
inspiring it uh it's funny because I
feel like when I saw you in the chain
mail and and in the the costumes and and
the the VFX everything in that opening
kind of prologue I thought I feel like I
understand who our Galadriel is and I
owe so much of it to your performance
I'm just curious like when you so what
everybody has to realize we didn't all
do this at the same time right so you
were in costume and and on set and then
I saw that footage I guess like a year
later yeah and and wrote this music I've
always wanted to know does it when you
finally heard it did it measure up did
it it was it what you wanted so
wonderful like I think I was talking to
you guys earlier about how when I was on
the horse that kind of there's kind of
like a Timeless feeling that kind of
people did this forever and we also sang
and felt stuff through music so it kind
of it made it all make sense and it also
it made me cry because there's such
sadness to it and such kind of I don't
know how you manage but such a feeling
of ancient sadness thank you the sadness
was what I was trying to grasp on to
because if she's just a hero I felt like
I was missing something really important
if I just wrote sort of a Hero theme so
I was really thinking about yeah having
that sadness in there but I also hope
that is is it kind of cool though to
have your own theme like oh my God I
mean I enjoyed your walkout I mean like
if I could just follow you and play your
music
come down to dinner
I don't know what do you think do you
know my my parents sometimes do that
um when I'm laid out of bed when I'm
visiting home